우리 키드밀리 님이 레버리지 투자를 굉장히 많이 하신다고 해가지고
장난 아니야?
레버리지 안 할 거면 투자 왜 합니까?
아아
근데 대학교 졸업하신 거예요?
우리 사장님 저울대 나왔어요!
근데 한 지 1년도 안 되신 거잖아요
5달? 3달?
눈이 제가 볼 때는 바닥을 보고는
막 누가 막 화택필립 푸왁 하면은
그냥 저걸 살 걸 약간 이러면서
화택필립을 날리셨어요?
보다 훨씬 많이 날렸죠
아 진짜?
전설적인 커뮤니티의 그 손실 막 그 정도는 아니에요
그럼 커뮤니티에 막 손자금이 엄청 나오는 건 다 래퍼들인가?
오늘 괴인협회가 아니고 주식이 또 힙합 아니겠습니까
오늘 우리 키드밀리와 함께 하겠습니다
어서오세요
뽀잇뽀잇뽀잇
안녕하세요 키드밀리입니다
오늘 조금 어떠세요?
왜냐면 또 패셔니스트 하시잖아요
아 왜 이렇게 이쁘시고 그런 소리를 돌리는 거잖아요 이거
일본 좋아한다고 하셨는데 일본풍으로
아 근데 너무
너무 외색이 짙은데요 이게
왜 일본은 어때서요?
저 일본 애니메이션 엄청 좋아하거든요
어때요?
아 그거 같아요 그
블레이드 러너
음
NL 대학 때 블레이드 러너로 리포트 냈습니다
거짓말하네 수업을 들었다고요?
근데 대학교 졸업하신 거예요?
우리 사장님 저울대 나왔어요
근데 내가 졸업장을 본 적이 없어
우리 사장님 지금 진짜 힙합한테 밀리는 거 같은데
무슨 소리야 전 인생 자체가 힙합이었는데
아이 왜요
뭐지 졸업반
근데 실제로 보니까 되게
재밌네요 화목하고
화목하다고요?
왜요 왜요
아이 아이 너무 화목하고
회사 같지 않다 이거 아닌가요?
근데 원래 힙합 씬도 그런 거 아니에요?
힙합 씬은 앞에나 뒤에나 비슷하죠
계속 안 좋아요? 계속 사이가 안 좋아요?
아 아니에요 저희 다 사이 좋아요
세상 싸운 건데?
아니야 아니야 아니야
스윙스 막 소리 지르고 난리 났는데
사이 좋고
아 좋아요?
네 근데 이제 약간 슈카님 실제로 뵈니까
옆머리 쪽이 좀 비시는 거 보니까
잡작하죠?
좀 약간 아니야 아니야
근데 키드밀리님이 슈카월드를 그렇게 자주 보신대요
거의 켜놓습니다 진짜로
국힙 원탑
이 정도 되니까 원탑을 하는 거예요
구독
철학이 담겨있는 힙합
소금빵으로 싸우신 것도 봤고
소금빵 사진도 아세요?
그러면은 여기서 제가 하나
사나이 테스트 한번 하도록 하겠습니다
요걸 딱 건너야 진정한 슈카팬이 될 수 있죠
아주 중요한 질문입니다
자 침착맨 대 슈카
답이 정해지는데
저요 저요 오늘 처음 했죠
야 웃음소리가 밖에서 나와
여기 크루예요
여기는 파김치 갱님 크루라고
우리는 크루여도 침착맨 대 슈카
침착맨
저 맞어
우리 크루여도 그런 거 없어
저도 그럼 침착맨
우리 키드밀리님이 레버리지 투자를 굉장히 많이 하신다고 해가지고
장난 아니야
레버리지 안 할 거면서 투자 왜 합니까
아 이거 어떻게 생각하십니까
지금 제일 많이 갖고 계신 게 호루랑 샌디스크 2배
기가 막히시네요 요즘에
이거 엄청 보셨겠네
근데 약간 현대 청년을 대표하는 느낌으로 투자하는
예
네?
예?
그래서 상승 오는 대로 맞고
그냥 뭐 하락 오는 대로 망하고
그거 회사 자금으로 하니 치는 건가요?
아니에요 아니에요
제가 한 달 전에
전쟁 왔을 때 한 번 크게 망했어요
예전에도 코로나 시절 때 투자한 네이버가 36만 원
지금 네이버는 그럼 아직 36통이 안 왔거든요
그래서 네이버는 결국엔 손절을 했고요
기회비용이 너무 아까워가지고
트럼프 대통령이 이란 전쟁 때문에 엄청 깨졌습니다
아 여기도 그치
스페인 가서 손절하셨잖아요
포지션을 가만히 있었으면
아 더 많이 벌었죠
와 기회비용이 어마어마하게 날아갔어요
저 시간을 돌리고 싶습니다
자 그러면 이제 약속된 시간이 끝났기 때문에
우리 크루여도 님은 여기 가서
여기가 제일 세
히드밀리 님 처음 뵈니까 어떠세요?
힙합 하시는 분은 데프콘 님 이후로 좀 교류가 잘 없으시잖아요
데프콘이 형이 예전에 저 라디오 같이 했거든요
근데 갑자기 나는 솔로에서 슈퍼스타가 되셔서
마지막 랩퍼를 뵌 지 좀 오래되시네요
랩 음악을 마지막으로 들었던 게 어떤 건지
힙합 혹시 안 들으시나요?
힙합!
현진영 선생님이 들으셨나?
근본이긴 해
현진 영 동진영 동
힙합이었다
드뉴스가 힙합이었니?
아 힙합이죠
드뉴스 힙합이죠
그래 그래
부스 때 삼성전자를 샀어요
아 근데 마지막으로 슈카님 보내드릴 텐데
방송으로 봤을 때 그 정돈된 모습
경제 유튜버
어떻게 약간 깬다 아니면 오히려 신선하다
아 근데 실제로 보니까 의외로 되게 교수님같이 생겨요
연식 있어
뭔가 잘못 말하면 약간 x 될 것 같은 느낌
정확해
웃긴 사람은 아니야 그죠?
예 맞아요
약간 무게감이 진짜 있어요
어디 있으면 슈카친구들 디스곡 하나 나올 것 같은데
아 안됩니다 안됩니다
X될 것 같아요
일단 이제 슈카님이 또 가셨으니까
본격적으로 저희가 한번 시작을 해보도록 하겠습니다
그 종목을 선택할 때 기준이
어 그래요
그게 너무 궁금해요
래퍼들은 누구 말을 듣고 사나요?
아 래퍼들이 주식하는 건 모르고 저는
말해도 되나?
네 말씀하세요
아 그래요?
AI로 만들어진
그 썸네일
이런 게 유행이야
트럼프는 이렇게 움직일 예정이야
가사 보면 정말 산전주전 다 겪은 것 같은데
세상 물정 잘 모르시네
이제 배우고 있어요 진짜 실제로
본을 투자라는 걸 처음 해봤고
뭐가 똥인지 된장인지 모르니까
근데 이분이 진짜 컨셉이 아니고
어제 트위치 방송하셨잖아요
방제가 코스피 7500이에요
그리고 음악 얘기를 안 하세요
제 방송은 음악 얘기와 밴이에요
음악 얘기를 옆에다 하단에 써놓더라고 하지 말라고
음악 얘기 밴
확실히 재밌는 걸 느끼는 게
이걸 하고 나서 옷을 아예 안 사고요
왜 부자들이 막 헐렁하게 하고 다니는지 알고 하고
어느 섹터가 불인가
진짜 주식이 진심이다
그러면 이제 힙합
힙합
힙합과 주식
그 연관관계에 대해서 얘기를 하고 싶은데
요즘에 힙합 하시는 분들이
얘기가 딱 두 가지 한대요
낫솔 아니면 주식 얘기
주식하게 생긴 친구들은 없는 것 같은데
양홍원님은 안 하시나요?
홍원님이 약간 성격이 진짜 레버리지 하실 것 같아가지고
오히려 본주에 박는 스타일이에요
아 진짜요?
오히려 건실한 청년이에요
떨어지면 아우 씨
하면서 바로 손조치실 것 같은
아유 아니에요
걔네 올라도 아우 씨 이러면서
왜 오르시 X가 이러면서
주머니에 이렇게
아 X가 왜 오르시 아 이거 몰라 이 안가면
저는 의외로 좀 주식이나 코인 이런 거 많이 사는 줄 알고
돈 많이 잃은 래퍼 뭐 이런 거 여쭤보려고 그랬는데
보통 그냥 철없다고 해야 되나
힙합에 충실하게 쓰지 않을까요?
다이아몬드 시계
플렉스하고
차 사고
인생에서 제일 비싸게 구매한 게 어떤 거예요?
중고차지 뭐
13년도 투싼?
13년도 투싼이 제일 비싸지 나는
에이
난 돈 생기면 무조건 주식에 다 박으니까
아 그러면은 피드멜리님은
카이엔 타고 다니시죠?
네네
제일 꿈에 차거든요
출금하시고 그냥 시원하게 사세요
아니면 중고로
하실 생각 있으세요?
아 저는 계속 할 거예요
바꿀 돈으로 주식할 거예요
와 진짜 마인드가
그러면은 그게 또 궁금한데
예술을 하시잖아요
네네
뭔가 가난할 때 예술이 잘 된다 이런 얘기가 있는데
제가 생각할 때는 사실 돈이 많으면
더 플렉스한 그런 가사가 나와서
더 신나서 랩 쓸 것 같거든요
어떨 때 더 랩이 잘 써지세요?
제 개인적으로는 가난할 때
아 물렸을 때
요즘 잘 돼요 그래서
아 요즘 생계형으로
근데 저는 사실 지금의 모습이 너무 좋지만
저는 1집에서
Why the fuck boys
네네네
지하철 탈 때
예를 들면
사람이 꽉 차 있어
약간 분노가 딱 끓어오를 때
그거 탁
헤드폰으로 딱 들으면서 가거든요
이 바보들 하면
저도 약간 출근할 때
직원이 한 번
그때 이제 두산에너필리티가
11만 원 넘어갔을 때
제가 두해비를 올인해 있거든요
아 그래요?
네 제가 4년 투자를 하고 있는데
평단이 만 원이에요
와 미친
바보들 하나님이 돈 벌지
집 샀어요 두산에너필리티로
경기도 구축입니다
와
뿔 뿔 뿔 뿔
아 이거 짜증나죠
갑자기 짜증나죠
아니 아니
요지는 그게 아니라
그게 아니라
제가
그 새끼
그 새끼라고
아니요 이 새끼라고
아 이 새끼
당신한테 한 거야
이 새끼
일반 힙합 밴드 중에 공감하는 게
주식이 오르잖아요
힙합 음악을 딱 들어요 출근길에
걸음걸이가 달라져요
오만하다 오만해
그렇지
자 그러면은
우리 키드밀리님의
포트폴리오를
와
진짜 큰 거 온다
오케이
와
여러분
샌디스크 레버리즈 아니에요 저거
맞아요 맞아요
근데 최근에 조금 조정된 게 있으면
한번 알려주시면 좋을 것 같아요
두해비를 들고 계시네요
근데 두해비를 팔았어요
지금 한번
지금 더 자극적이게 됐는데
지금?
지금 코로 다니고
룰루레몬에다가
아이온큐 두배
샌디스크 두배
속쓸
룰루레몬은 왜 있는 거지?
룰루레몬은
전망이 좀 밝지 않나요?
빠질 만큼 빠져서
오늘 10% 넘게 빠졌더라고요
공매도 7만큼 쳤죠?
아직 덜 밀었나?
그거 모르시고
이건 또 할 말이 많은데
저는 AI 투자맨이거든요
AI의 도움을 받기 위해서
인베스팅 프로라는 거 아시나요?
인베스팅 닷컴에 결제를 해서
룰루레몬을 분석을 시켰어요
그리고 제가 제 옆에
미국인 친구가 한 명 있는데
아
돈 운용하는 친구란 말이에요
걔도 룰루레몬에 들어가 있길래
들어갔는데
안 오르더라고요
그래서
지금은 이제
속쓸이 가장 많아졌고요
속쓸 평단이 18만원
SNXX
샌디스크 두배
평단 20만원
MUU
마이크론 두배
평단 60만원
하이닉스 평단 140
코루 평단 130
죄송한데 주식을 하는 건 맞나요?
이거 그냥
도파민을 그냥 다
삼성전자 22만원
이렇게 해서 많은 순서입니다
저는 이제 이름만큼 복구하면은
레버리지 끊을 거예요
아 지금 복구하고
복구 때문에 레버리지 하시는 거예요?
복구 때문에 하는 거예요
그리고 제가 눈여겨보는 녀석들이 있어요 사실
돈주로
저는 마이크로소프트
왜요?
지금 좋을 거라 생각해요
왜죠?
실적이랑
뭔가 떨어진 게 없는데
MS가 오픈AI한테 물린 건 아시죠?
네 압니다
오 뭐야
상무님과 대화가 되는
전문적인
최근에 기세도 안 좋은 거 알고 있어요
캐시가 없어요 걔들이
네네네
그래도 마이크로소프트가 조금
역사적 저점이 아닐까
근데 그 역사적 저점이라는 거에 기준이
어떤 걸 보고
좀 기준이라고 생각하시는 거예요?
인베스팅 프로웹
걔가 한
418달러 부는 사라던데요?
난 인베스팅 프로 돌려서
하시는 거 처음 봤어
프로로 해서 자기가 분석은 하는데
시키는 대로 하는 거 처음 봤어
좀 배워야 될 것 같아요 그래서
그래서 얼마 전에 워렌버피지 본 책 중에
현명한 투자자라고
어떡하냐
갈 때까지 다 갔다
꼭대기입니다 여러분
근데 지금 종목들을 보아하니
삼성전자 하이닉스 말고는
네이버도 지금 다 파신 것 같고
국장에는 크게 뭐가
좀 미련이 없으신 것 같아요
그래서 이제 들어오는 돈을
지금은 이제
하이닉스에 넣자
200만 원 됐는데 오늘
아 근데 또 떨어지지 않을까 어제처럼
그러면 눌림목이 한 번씩 있지 않을까
눌림목
눌림목이라는 용어도 한다
이거 근데 진짜 눌리는 거 아니에요 이거?
저를 뭘로 보시는 거예요?
사실 저는 스포일러만 보고
그냥 토스증권
7시간 순위보고
급상승맨
그냥 그런 건 줄 알았어요
거래대금 맨
5월 22일에 이제 또 나오니까
하이닉스 2배
아 ETF도 사시게요?
22일 밀렸습니다 그거
아 밀렸어요?
22일에 국민성장평도 나와가지고
5월 말로 밀렸어요
아 더 좋아요
5월 말에 실현자 들어오는 날이라서
실현자라고 이제 저희 같은 경우는
노래 실현이나 이제 목소리로 이제 실제로 연주한 사람들이 받는 돈이 있거든요
아 근데 이게 어떻게 보면 연금저축처럼 꼬박꼬박 들어오는
연금이네요
꼬박꼬박 들어오죠
그것만 해도 다 복구할 수 있는 거 아니야?
에이 아닙니다 아닙니다
노래방에서 맨날 뭐 부르고 하면은
그거는 이제 저작권이고
저작권이고
근데 막 뭐 그렇게 화려한 세계는 아니에요
근데 그거 다 들어오면 다 레버리지로 받을 수 있는데
이제 생각해봐야죠
아티스트가 좋은 게
현금 흐름이 따박따박 월급처럼
너무 변동성이 심해요
전 월급마저 레버리지예요 사실
아 그러네
그러면 래퍼들은 그런 돈 들어오면 뭐 해요?
부속 사는 거
아 롤리롤리 사고
네 롤리도 사고
그럼 명품으로 한 몇백 산 다음에 현금 영수증 하나요?
아니요 저는 했어요
건실한 청년
하락을 해가지고
해야 되거든요
매입세 공제 받아야 되거든요
아 그리고 저희 같은 경우는 이제 악기 사면은 세액 공제가 돼가지고
래퍼가 악기가 필요해요?
마이크랑 음향기
비트치고 해야지
죄송한데 뭐 다 무반주로 그냥
날까기 아니에요
아니 아니 나는
예술가 돼요
무슨 봉이 김선발도 아니고
미안합니다 저 잘 몰라요
컴퓨터도 이렇게 사고
소프트웨어도 파는 것도 있어야지 그것도 이제
좀 공제가 되는 걸로 알고 있어요
아 역시 사장님이니까
공제라는 또 용어를 쓰시네
댓글에 의외로 존나 건질하네
씨발
씨발 새끼가
뭔가 래퍼들의 하루가 갑자기 궁금해지는데
유튜브에서 본 거는
9시에 3시에 일어나서
그때 작업실 출근하고
커피 이제 아메리카노 하나 마시면서
비트 찍고
곡 나왔다 하고
저녁때서 클럽에 갔다가
매일?
아니 아니 그러니까 뭔가
월, 화, 수, 목, 금
느낌 느낌
어때요? 래퍼의 하루
그런 사람도 있지 않을까요?
누가 그럽니까? 누가
알죠? 누군지
몇 년 전에 저도 그랬어요 근데
같이 함께하는 친구들이
클럽은 혼자 갈 수 없으니까
그러면 래퍼들은 예를 들면 클럽 갈 때
그냥 들어갈 수 있어요?
그냥 들어가는 건 기본인데 좀 유명하면
돈 안 내고
아 돈 안 내도 돼요?
테이블도 다 잡아줘요?
테이블 같은 경우에는 좀
급이 없는 친구는 급이 있는
같이 가야 되는구나
거기에 이제
동행으로
그럼 저는 궁금한 게
래퍼들끼리 모였을 때 술 같은 거 먹잖아요
그건 다 끝나고 엠빵을 하나요?
죄송해요
궁금하긴 해
궁금하잖아 솔직히
저는 근데 재수 없을 수도 있는데
클럽에서 돈 안 써본지 8년 됐어요
비싼 술 먹어도?
그럼 누가 내요 그거?
그냥 다 줘요
클럽에서?
그래서 이상한 버릇이 든 게
공짜로?
내가 돈을 내야 돼?
근데 이제 너무 자주 안 가죠
너무 자주 가면 별로 안 신기해요
저 새끼 또 왔네 약간 이러면서
아니 댓글에 원재현 클럽에서도
위장 주가 확인하는 거 목격했다고?
아니 댓글에 원재현 클럽에서도 위장 주가 확인하는 거 목격했다고?
그래서 못 보게 프라이빗 필름 이것도 했는데
이렇게 보거든요
자꾸 토스에서 알람을 주니까
래퍼들 중에 청년도약 계좌는 래퍼 있어요?
나이는 되실 거 같은데
없을걸요?
그 정도로 건실한 사람은 없을걸요?
그거 궁금하다
그러니까 처음에는 저작권도 안 들어오고
완전 헝그리 때
어떻게 돈을 생계를 유지하는 거예요?
알바했었죠
근데 저는 다행히 그때 당시에
인데고 뮤직 들어가고 얼마 안 됐을 때였어요
그래가지고 저희 같은 프리랜서 회사들은
들어간다고 월급을 주진 않잖아요
이거 완전 거의 증권사처럼
근데 왜 거기서 욕을 먹고 그랬어요?
제가 뭐예요?
욕 안 먹었어요
아니 영상 보니까 스위스가 막 욕하더만
그냥 컨텐츠 컨텐츠
딩고 컨텐츠 보신 거구나
어지럽네
그냥 욕할 때 욕 나오는구나 하고 꺾고 나
꺾고 나
이런 뜻이
저 그때 이제 여자친구랑 헤어져가지고
제 여자친구 집에 얹혀 살았었단 말이에요
헤어지면 나와야 돼요 거기서
근데 이제 맞물려가지고 이제 회사 계약을 해서
회사에서 작업실을 줬어요 조그만
거기에서 먹고 자고 그랬어요
다행히 얼마 안 가서
홈모노라는 노래가
조금 잘 돼가지고
이제 그때는 이제 생활이 됐죠
홈모노 벌써 다 외웠거든요
메이드 카페 가서 4천에는 썼다고 쓰셨는데
그 메이드 카페가 그거 요이 뭐 나거나래 뭐 그건가?
우리나라도 있어요 메이드복 입고 이렇게 서빙해주는데
제가 생일 때마다 갑니다
그런 서비스가 있거든요 메이드 카페에
얼마 주면 앞에서 댄스
얼마 주면은 나만을 위한 노래 불러주는
이거 임방이잖아
가끔씩 긴급 라이브 하면
사모님이 종목 상담해주고 슈퍼챗 하잖아요
그 슈퍼챗
메이드 셔...
메이드?
알메이드
한번 입고 해주시면 안 돼요?
10만 원 줄 때마다 하나씩 벗어?
근데 한번만 입어주시고 하시면 안 돼요?
제가 사드릴까요?
그러면
제가 입으면 같이
내가 사줬는데 왜 같이 입어요
저는 그러면 집사복 하죠
메이드 말고 집사도 있어요
그러면 한번 미국 주식 특집으로 해서
키드밀리님이랑 안성문님이랑 입고
한번 수금 한번 제대로 땡겨볼까요?
그걸 해서 제가 얻는 게 뭡니까?
꽃지 나눠드릴게요
누군가가 10만 원 이상 쏘지 않으면
5분이 지나면
갈아입어
일반복으로 갈아입어
입어버려
이제 제가 우리 애가 커가지고
이러고 못해
그럼 저희가 뭐 상무업 상무업 이런 거 해?
동사화가
근데 오늘 포트폴리오는 제가 봤는데
정상이 아니죠
원래 정상적인 투자자는 아닌데
벌고 있으니까 할 말이 별로 없어서
어도비 빼고는 별로
최호님한테 막
이거 레버리지 위험한 거 아닙니까
이런 거 좀 얘기해 달라고 했는데
아 근데 알려주세요
위험은 하죠
저는 이제 하락할 때 대비를
언젠가는 하락이 오니까
제가 왜 레버리지가 불리한 전략인지
엑셀로 살짝 정리했고
이거 진짜 아무데서나 못 듣는 거거든요
여기 보시면 100으로 시작했다고 쳐요 제가
이거 100이 될 거 같잖아요
댓글에 진짜 엑셀 방송이라고
상무업 상무업
돈을 쏘으면서 얘기해 이런 거랑
어 너 부도도 엑셀?
상무업 상무업
마이크도 왜
잠깐만요
아 갑자기
잠깐만
아 씨
아 잠깐만
아 근데 이렇게 하면
올라가는 국명만 레버리지는 좋은 거예요
반대로 이제 곧버스는
빠지는 국가만 좋은 거
아 저는 절대
숏을 치지 않습니다
건실한 청년
사실 잃은 것 중에
네이버도 큰 지분이 있지만
제일 큰 게
코르랑
어?
아 손절을 한 번 했구나
네 손절을 했어요 제가
원래 한
700 몇 달러였거든요
2월 28일쯤에
근데 갑자기 3월 1일 2일 되니까
갑자기
맞아요
어차피 막 10% 빠진다
네 맞아요
패닉셀 하고
그리고 이제 복구하겠다고
숏을 쳤어요
근데 숏을 그렇게 길게 가져가지 않고
숏을 좀 벌었어요
소스 같은 거였을 거예요
번 다음에
미친놈처럼
급등주를 탕 버린 거예요
너무 공감되는 게
이게 한 번 손절 나가고 나면은
이거를 복구만 해야지라는 생각으로
진짜 미친놈처럼
급등주 타는 게
이게 진짜 그냥 다 국룰인가 보다
와
근데 급등주 같은 건 법으로
검지해야 되는
불법해야 되는
그냥 사실 인터넷 사이버도 막
본질을 파악했네 벌써
솔직히 급상승 탭 같은 거 없애야 된다고 생각하는데
손절하고 딱
매네라 올 때 있거든요
그러면 이제 그거 한 200% 300%
중국 주식 보면은
열 받아가지고 거기에 또 추격해서 타는데
그럼 또 내려가고
그 패턴을 읽는 그 알고리즘이 있습니다
개미들이
자기도 모르게 한 그 패턴을 읽어서
개미를 그래서 훌쩍 패가지고
털어먹는 알고리즘이 따로 있어요
아
감옥을 안 가나요?
네?
그럼 약간 이제 코덱스 200
인덱스 이런 거 하고 싶진 않으세요?
지루해요
아
이미 절여져 버린 거 같아
전 단일주 하고 싶어요
투사애너미리티 괜찮은데
두 앱을 왜 들어가셨어요 근데?
뭐 전력이 뜬다길래 그냥
그 AI 영상이 알려져
아 AI
요즘 전력이 뜬다는 거 알고 있어?
요즘 난리 난 이 종목
이 전력 놓치면 큰일 납니다
자 들어봐
다음 반도체가 될 종목들은 이거야
이러면서
그 감이 들 때가 있지 않아요?
아 이건 간다
이 주식은
일단 이 투자는 간다
제가 촉이 좀 좋은 편이 아니에요
근데 미국 반도체에 투자하신 어떤
서랍은 있으신가요?
그 옛날부터 어른들이 했던 말이
국장할 바에는
아 미자
주식 시작을
작년 9월에 했어요
그래서 그 말이 아직 허용될 때였거든요
맞아요 맞아요
그때는 이제 또 건실하게 했거든요
구글에 넣고
재미가 없는 거예요
한 달 지났는데 2% 올라있고
어이C
그러면 예금을 하지
확 했는데 막 토스 막 고수 막
이 사람 막
말로 부자예요
막 명함 달려있잖아요
맞아요 명함 있지
딱 들어갔는데
이 사람 투자 내역을 보니까 막
이상한 영어들이 있어
기업이 아니야
딱 봐도
막 3배로 오른대요
이건 좋은 거 아닌가
탁탁탁 하다가
미장 뽑을 때
이틀 딜레이가 있잖아요
그걸 못 참아서 이제
삼정산익이 오르길래
호루에 탄 거예요
그리고 제가 또 좀
사팔사팔하는 것도 문제였어요
제가 샌디스크 레버리지 나온 첫날에
거기에다가 몰빵해놨거든요
근데 그거 지금까지 들고 있었으면
장난 아니었더라고요
그럼 지금 전체 자산에
몇 프로가 주식에 들어가 계세요?
한 반 정도
절반은요?
절반은 그냥 들고 있어요
캐시로?
네
어쨌든 회사장 교물로 나갈 수도 있으니까
자본을 채워놔야 될 수도 있으니까
그럼 저 궁금한 게
이번에 PUV에 이제
오카시 님 들어오셨잖아요
동생분들한테 이런 주식 경제관념을
전파를 하나요?
왜요 왜?
어우 좋은 거 같지 않아요
제가 알려주면 좋게 배우지 못할 거 같아요
니네는 이런 거 하지 마라
근데 어차피 말해도 듣지도 않아요
저 그때 그 나이 때도
말해준 형들 진짜 많았거든요
듣지도 않았어요
그러면서 막 뭐
아이팔 사고 람보르기인가
그 래퍼들은 사실 차도 있고
금도 사실 많이 있을 거 같아서
왜냐면은 금 맨날 목걸이
목걸이로 되어있는 금형물은 많을걸요?
그 닥친 진짜 아니에요?
아 진짜겠죠?
클럽에서 술 먹다가
잠깐 풀어놓으면
그러면 클럽이나 이런 데서 자기 물풀어 놓고 오면
다음날 클럽에 전화해서
잃어버렸다 혹시 있냐고 물어보고 이래요?
아 저 한 번 그런 적 있어요
공연하다가
칙 하고 떨어져 나와가지고
아 못 찾았어요
못 찾지 그거
번개장터 뒤져보고
당근마켓 뒤져보고
그러면 사실 저희가
히드밀리 님이 오셨다고
아 그 시간인가요?
오늘 알상무 님이 주식을 알려드렸으니까
히드밀리 님이 저희한테 랩 피드백 한 번
저희가 평소에 프리스타일로 비트 틀어놓고 막 서로 뵀거든요
이걸 이렇게 하고 싶어하는 사람은 처음 봤어요
보통 시켜도 안 하거든요
저 이거 이제 헤드셋 쓰면 되나요?
아아
샤라웃 박지원 회장님
오케이
렛츠고
예
안녕 날 소개하지
이름은 백이웃 직업은 슈카 타카리
경제적 자유에 의해 난
오늘도
야근 포괄임 금지
내 편집시간 6시간
쎄빠지게
근데 그 중 2시간은
니니님 얼굴 보정
아직도 모르겠어
여기서 내 직무
기획자 편집자
아니면 그냥 딴따라
워
두애비로 오르면 쏟아지는 카톡
이제는 느껴져 달라진 내 위치
그래서 난 이미 올라와서 뛰지
역시 나는 니네 머리 위에 있지
워워워
상무님 호텔실라 감사합니다
상무님 대우건설도 감사합니다
에에?
아니
코스닥 150은 죽었나요?
뭐 이거 도대체 각인가요?
중도금낼 돈으로 한 장 들어갔어요나
코스닥 이제 출발한단 여의도 전문가들
난 그럼 거기 중지올리고 한마디 뱉어
여기까지입니다
뿌이 뿌이 뿌이
왜 이렇게 길게 하셨어요?
저희 오늘 하루종일 이거 벌스 쓰고 서로 피드백했어요
어이
근데 약간 라임이 없어요
자 백이웃님은 키드밀리와 함께 가실 수 없습니다
불구덩이
두 번째 사이퍼 갑니다
개나 소나 주식하는 세상이 됐어
코스피는 8초 코스닥은 1000이배
하지만 니 계좌는 여전히 바다
3전 한익현차
언제부터 가치를 봤다고 니들이 같이 있고 같이 얘기해
니들이 얘기할 때부터 곱창을 X같아서 그게 지랄이었어
니들이 수돗물 스페이스 쉽은말씀 하겠지
하지만 거기에 니 자리가 있을까?
난 쇼 쨍이들의 왕
1838 니들이 네이버와 하나비 키우고 있을 때
난 니 K를 쇼치해
나는 기세
고요
아 좋은데요?
기세가 좋은데요?
아 녹음은 기세입니다
아 죄송합니다
우승, 우승후보 등장
요 모니터 아픈 전쟁터
수조원씩 던지고 튀는 너
우리 뒤 개미들
비단 음을 넣어 낸 그냥
달갑괴물 공매도로 장난치
너는 그냥 딸깍괴물 공매도로 장난치
비겁한 스킬
외인들 매도 폭탄 이건 거 이 테러
박스 꺼내 가둬놓는 니 인생은 에러
그만 좀 챙겨 한국 돈 프로핏
국장이 놀이터냐 당장 스탑잇
셀코리아 웃기시네
우린 끝까지 홀드해
민다고 밀리겠냐 코스피
어림없지 우린 네버 안 밀리
와 우승후보다
와 뭐야
근데 중간중간 약간 정상수 들리네
정상 수 코스 삐
일단 그럼 3등부터
3등은 피디님
2등은 알상문님
1등은 니린님
제일 랩 같은 랩이었어요
감사합니다 이 영광을
우리 키드밀리님에게 와 와 와
1등이 이유만
약간 저 정도로 진심이었나 싶어가지고
저희가 또 힙합 문화를 너무 좋아하다 보니까
직원들이 만약 이렇게 하고 있으면 어떻게 합니다?
아 POV에서?
랩을요?
새끼들 미쳤나
그리고 이제 증권사에서도
김정일인데 네이버 같은 거 사고 있으면
그렇게 하고
네이버 같은 거라니요
아 저 배워야 되는 거 있어요
이제 이 반도체 불장이 끝나고
나는 어디로 가야 하는가
이 돈으로
알려주세요 알버지
근데 이게 빠진다는 게 어떻게 이 구분을 해요?
만약에 어제처럼 빠졌다가
오늘처럼 갑자기 다 회복할 수도 있잖아요
그러니까 오늘이 안 좋은 거예요
양봉이 좀 났다가
윗골이 난 근 은봉이 났다가
올라가긴 했지만 고점을 못 들었거든요
이게 되게 그 패턴상
흉락이 보이는 그런 패턴이에요 1번이
오늘 이렇게 많이 오르지 말고 조금 오르고
여기서 멈췄으면 괜찮은데
오늘도 또 위에서 산 사람들이
있다는 거예요
끝까지 밀고 올라가는 사람들이
그 사람 평단이 또 높은 거예요
근데 아직은 괜찮아요
아직은 괜찮아요
특히 하이닉스는 괜찮고
근데 밀리님도 제가 이제 약간 감이 있으시다고 느끼는 게
조치돼 있지 않고 빠질 때를 생각하신다는 게
어느 정도 이제 약간 내공이 쌓이신 거 같아요
근데 한 지 1년도 안 되신 거잖아요
5달 3달
그거 치고는 뭔가 너무 많은 것을
침착해
눈이 제가 볼 때는 바닥을 보고는 눈이야
이게 잃은 금액만큼의 뭔가가 자꾸 떠오르더라고요
길을 지나가다 보면
막 좋은 차 보이고
뒷보이고 하면은 막 누가 막 파텍 필립 파악 하면은
그냥 저걸 살 걸 약간 이러면서
파텍 필립을 날리셨어요?
보다 훨씬 많이 날렸죠
아 진짜?
그래서 1년 10년
뭐 그렇게 막 엄청난 전설적인 커뮤니티의 그 손실
막 그 정도는 아니에요
그럼 커뮤니티에 막 손재금이 엄청 남은 건 다 래퍼들인가?
아니 근데 사실 뭐 쉬운 건 아니지만
솔직히 말하면 행사 몇 번 하면은 채우는 거 아니에요?
약간 환상 같은 거예요
아 그래요?
나가는 비용이 꽤 많아요 그리고
차량 렌트비도 있고
매니저 월급도 의상비도 있고 메이크업
아 근데 래퍼들도 그렇고 연예인들도 그렇고
그런 건 좀 힘들겠다
우리는 그냥 뭐 반팔티 입고 나가도 되는데
무조건 좀 정리되고 옷도 막 잘 입고 나가야 되고
저는 안 그렇긴 해요
근데 연예인들은 그렇겠죠?
연예인이시잖아요
아 저는 제가 연예인 아니라고 생각해요
연예인 막 연예인 막 이 정도까지는 아니라고 생각해요
일반인이 마이너스 몇 억 손실을 막 그렇게
일반인 허들이 너무 낮으신 거 아니에요 지금?
집 하나 사셨다고?
그래 재수가 없었어 그동안
그러니까 회사 대충 다니는 거 같고
화이팅
알겠습니다 자 그러면 우리 밀리 님
우리 오늘 이렇게 1시간 지속 한 40분 동안
너무 빨라 시간 진짜 너무 빠르다
긴 시간 진짜 후딱 갔어요
아 아쉬워
어떠셨어요?
네?
지금 미국장 보시는 거 같은데요?
제가 살짝 살짝 걸쳐서 봤는데
알림이 떠 있더라고요
토스 증권에서 알림 온 거 아니야?
세이브
아 오선의 세이브
이란 전쟁 여팔 원유 재고 사상 최소급
숙소로 감소
쥐랄하네 갑자기
그 연준 회장 연설이 내일인가요?
내일은 투표
케빈호 씨가 이사는 됐어요
이사들이 모여가지고 투표하는 거
그게 내일이고
저는 그게 제일 무서워요
지금 말씀하신 그 부분이랑
그 중국이랑 만나고
회담 회담
위중회담 오 뭐야
아니 진짜 세게 정세를
세이브 탁
인사이트나 이런 건 되게 건실한데
종목이 레버리지
그러니까 아니 슈카월드 보지 뭐 세게 정세 알지
근데 이거 어떻게 레버리지를 연결해
제가 그래서 어저께 폭락해가지고
아 나스닥 멸망의 날이다 하고 새벽에
새벽에 사실 방송을 한 번 더 켰어요
열받아가지고
그날 사실 롤도 6연패 해가지고
되는 게 없는 거예요
하이닉스 대폭락 막 이러면서 막
콱 하고 막 나스닥 대폭락 하고 이래가지고
롤도 팍 해가지고 한 판 했는데
키보드를 팍 쳤어요
근데 키보드도 고장 난 거예요
그래서 결국 고쳤어요
교치고 재밌는 게임이 좀 있나 보다가
이제 프레그마타라는 게임이 있는 거예요
사람들이 이렇게 네 명이서 달기지로 갔는데
이제 미래에
거기도 AI가 정복하는 세계야
막 하다가 AI들이 고장나서
고장난 AI들을 제가 총 쏴서 죽이는 거예요
야 이 XX가 오늘 반도체 쇼
오시니까 이 새끼 머리에도 반도체가 있겠지 하면서
이제 팍 다 죽이면서
레버리지 끊으셔야 되는 거 아니에요?
반도체 쇼티지나가지고
그래서
여기서 왜 반도체 쇼티지나
아니 보면 볼수록
탐나죠
오니코믹스식 인재세요
예
아니 그 뉴스도 다 팔로우 하시는 거예요?
하죠 세이브 덕분에
세이브가 오선 님 그거는 아시죠?
알죠 알죠
저도 오선 님이 라방 보면서
아 이거 왜 맨날 라방 봐야 되지
막 편하게 해줄 수 없나 했는데
마침 그 분이 다 만들어 주신 거예요
오선 님 저희한테
광고료 주셔야 돼요
주셔야 될 거 같은데
주시죠
역대 게스트 분 중에서
가장 잘 녹아진 분이 아닌지
감사합니다
저 너무 오고 싶었어요
이 미친놈들 사이에서
그냥 저희 직원인 거 같고
아무튼 우리 진짜 엑셀 방송
아 샤라웃 키드밀리
아 오늘 개미는 지금
감사합니다
샤라웃 p.o.b